on the house Leslie oh thank you
sort of a gay hero
spending the summer doing a lot of Zoo
promotions
parrots live a very long time so we had
a birthday party for a parent that
turned 60.
those are very smart so we had them
graduate from college and they like to
fling their feces so we were hoping that
they would clean their hats but they
has fun and feces
the Pawnee Zoo recently purchased two
South African black-footed Penguins tux
and flipper and as part of our Zoo
promotion we are going to give them a
marriage ceremony
because they mate for life
tucks do you take flipper to be your
lawfully wedded wife
I do I do
by the power invested in me from the
Department of Parks and Recreation I Now
pronounce you husband and wife
[Applause]
oh
foreign
okay well at least you're married
are they making babies
well not those two those are both boy
penguins
I'm sorry tucks and flipper are both
boys so you should have pronounced some
husband and husband technically that's
awesome
there's just Leslie hey hey
this is my boyfriend Derek this is
Derek's boyfriend Ben hey
oh wait sorry what's the situation what
do you mean how does this work
Derek is gay but he's straight for me
but he's gay for Ben and Ben's really
gay for Derek and I hate Ben
it's not that complicated yeah oh yeah
sure the thing about youth culture is I
don't understand it
so what can I do for you guys they just
really wanted to meet you because you're
kind of like their hero now oh oh April
oh it please it was just Penguins no I'm
a public servant and I'm not allowed to
take a political stance but you did and
it was awesome yeah none of the other
politicians ever take a stand and it
means a lot to the whole gay community
oh it does and we're gonna have this
party tomorrow night at the Bulge and we
had something to ask you we really want
you to be the guest of honor oh my it'd
be amazing if you came yeah you have to
come
who who made this we did we did how
Photoshop what computers oh
really a gay bar yeah especially with
that heterosexual Cowboy greeting us on
the way in where's my drink now there's
a bar on H Street called pictures and
catchers you can go there yeah
okay listen here's the plan our position
is we have no position so let's just say
thank you for the party but we
regretfully decline your offer to honor
me oh my God I can't believe you came
here
you are looking hot oh thank you Ben I'm
really enjoying this hug
oh nice but I need to tell you something
this one is on us well if it's free
Leslie no
[Applause]
she's Leslie no she wants to recruit you
know oh my okay
gentlemen first of all I would just like
to say thank you so much for throwing me
this party especially on a night when
the Colts are playing
okay
ah this is green
[Applause]
okay well I wanted to tell you that I
wasn't really trying to take a stand
when I married those penguins
[Music]
[Applause]
Wesley knows in the building
I'm having such a nice time tonight I've
met many interesting people and there's
two bisexual guys here and I got both of
their phone numbers
good morning
show me what I Got Heaven have fun last
night I had three drinks named after me
so that's pretty fun plus Ben and Derek
are taking me shopping on Saturday and
we are gonna find out my actual bra size
some kind of like Queen of the gays
bully for you what if anything can miss
note do to make it right Joan we don't
want to be unreasonable of course not we
think that she should separate the
Penguins annul the marriage uh
reimbursed the taxpayers for the cost of
the wedding of course and then resign oh
is that it that would do it anything
else want me to jump off a building
perform Harry Carey move to a different
town no I Kid full of ideas here today
this is the reason why people don't go
into politics
because you know I bust my ass for the
people in the city and I can't win I
have one night of fun with some of the
best dancers I've ever danced with and
suddenly everybody's freaking out yeah
if you let Penguins Get Married where
does it end I mean would you let me
marry my guinea pig because I I really
do want to marry my guinea pig I'll take
my answer off the air I think that's a
valuable point you know attendance is up
30 At The Zoo by the way you're welcome
that penguin wedding was cute damn it
and I'm not going to annul it I'd ask
you to reconsider well I'd ask you to
stop asking me because it's not gonna
happen Marcia is that right last time I
tried to I don't think I I murdered
anyone or or had an affair or did drugs
but I apologize I apologize for having
fun and for making something cute
where are you from originally oh no
no so you will not be annoying no I will
not be a nulling no
look at him
they're just in their own little
penguin love Bubble
I guess that's what it's like when you
meet your mate and know you're gonna be
together forever
so I transferred the Penguins to a zoo
in Iowa
gay marriage is legal there so hopefully
they'll be happy at least we'll be
together
slide they might die but it would be so
cute
you know why tonight's fun because
everyone's so gay
and they know how to have fun and the
dancing
just it's everyone is just who they are
and who they are is just Stone Cold gay